elle absorbe des millions de tonnes de
CO2
et abrite des milliers d'espèces
animales
[Musique]
la forêt d'Afrique centrale est la
deuxième plus grande forêt du monde
après l'Amazonie
parmi les pays qu'il recouvre
il y a le Gabon
ici les hommes ont appris à protéger et
à vivre avec l'immense manteau vert qui
occupe 90% de leur pays
[Musique]
ce matin là Saturnin les kangas se
réveille au beau milieu de la forêt ce
passionné a pour habitude de dormir tout
en haut de ce mirador pour pouvoir
observer les animaux sauvages
c'est de voir s'il y a pas les animaux
qu'on peut observer ce matin nous avons
des éléphants
le pays est devenu un sanctuaire pour
des dizaines d'espèces menacées comme
ces gorilles
pour les animaux parce qu'il retrouve
tout ici ils vont tout retrouver
le sel minéraux vous avez de l'eau qui
coule
après ces observations matinales
Saturnin qui sont perçoit au programme
randonné dans la forêt divine d'eau
bonjour l'un des 13 parcs nationaux du
Gabon comme la zone est protégée
personne ne peut s'y aventurer seul il
faut obligatoirement être escorté par
des garde-forestiers ils sont des
centaines à surveiller en permanence les
visiteurs et les animaux la des espèces
qui sont très menacées comme les
éléphants et les buffs les gorilles sont
très menacés par les braconniers donc on
est obligé de protéger l'OPAC
en 20 ans plus de 2 millions d'hectares
de forêt ont été placés sous protection
au Gabon et le gouvernement va encore
plus loin une station de recherche
dédiée à la préservation de la
biodiversité à ouvert ses portes au cœur
du parc
longueur de la tige
nous avons 63 cm Charles bilambi il faut
s'harmonie ok gère le reboisement de la
forêt dans cette petite nurserie il font
pousser des quais vas-y Go un arbre
victime du trafic de bois la forêt c'est
notre vie les arbres jouent un rôle
important pour notre équilibre mondial
nous on doit les revoiser c'est la
mission que nous avons dans quelques
centaines d'années voici à quoi
ressembleront les petits protégés des
scientifiques des géants ici de couloirs
blanches qui absorbe chaque année 4% de
nos émissions mondiales de CO2
et cette nature unique au monde attire
des visiteurs bien au-delà des
frontières du Gabon ces touristes
américains ont choisi d'y passer un mois
loin des villes des hôtels de luxe et
loin du confort
tout à l'heure l'eau rentre mais ça va
c'est drôle vous êtes courageux ouais je
crois c'est ce que mes enfants disent en
tout cas
[Rires]
après trois heures de pirogue voici les
époustouflantes chute de Kangoo
trésor du parc divine d'eau récemment
classé au patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO
cette nuit s'est touriste aventurier
s'endormiront sous des tentes un peu
plus loin
au cœur de cette forêt
temple mondial de la biodiversité
[Musique]